coming back to Colombia with all this
work in hand it's a little bit like
running the film in Reverse and it's
like bringing my kids back to where I be
you know this is where your father grew
up my influence of Colombia was not only
through the gesture but it's also
through the coursework and through my
peers my friends were all literally
inclined I'd seem to hang out with with
people in in English and in the liberal
arts rather than sciences and then and
Colombia at that point and probably
still is a hugely literate articulate
group of people and somehow the words in
the literary aspect of drawing cartoons
became as important as the drawing well
when I first came to Colombia I was
intrigued by the fact that there was a
campus humor magazine the gesture which
at that point had a long tradition of as
a kind of incubator for a lot of people
who had gone on talents who had become
in become national figures and
cartoonists as well as John held jr and
charles saxon most notably I had started
drawing when I was in high school and I
was just babbling and playing around
with cartooning and with drawing and I
didn't really know what I wanted to do
but somehow that magazine here the
gesture made it extremely plausible for
me to continue what I had started in
high school
in the process of starting to work more
and more as a from a freshman on I
started to develop whatever was in my
mind and whatever was in my hand it's
just slowly bit by bit it was kind of
like coming out of the UN's no the first
it was the snout and then the ears and
the eyes it was you know the whole
question of how I was going about my
work and what I was really interested in
the development was unplanned I didn't
know what I was doing I just kept at it
and in truth this is I can almost say
subsequently fifty five years later I
sort of know what I'm doing but but I'm
not exactly sure even I started working
very small when I was a jester they were
tiny because I was not a draftsman in
any significant way
so it was tentative and my sense of
scale I mean the scale is increased as
I've gotten on and my career it was
working along with drawing and so I
started out with gesture and small
drawings because that's what I knew how
to do part of it was the material and in
fact it was the crow quill pen and ink
and a croco appendix in very it's kind
of painful to work with in a way it's
it's slow and it's very detailed so I
really didn't know that much about
drawing and materials and size and scale
the crow quill pen was all I knew so I
used that and it lent itself to working
very small it didn't dance on the page
in the same way that I discovered later
I could do with different kinds of
materials and different kind of
instruments say what I use now is a pen
or series of pens depending on there
with that allow the hand to just
play much more freely on a piece of
paper and react to the paper drawings
got bigger as I started to get more
adapt and also I think at the time in
the 70s there was a sense of scale
there's a whole attitude toward scale
and we're in paintings sculptures gotten
much much larger the wall was to be
considered and somehow that influenced
me and then I started to draw larger and
larger and larger because the details
and the feel of the hand and the way my
hand worked on the paper it was more
comfortable getting the kind of
expression and the kinds of details and
the kinds of color and the drawings that
I really felt comfortable with and now I
would be extremely that's my comfort
range I can't go back this relationship
of pen and hand and brain has always
fascinated me because there's no answer
I can give to to questions of
development and how when I started out I
would end up here I don't know no clue
it's a kind of evolutionary process I've
controlled it of course to be sure I've
brought all kinds of increasing
knowledge to the work but I'm still
mystified in a kind of nice way about
how it all works and when some of this
hand like people say how do you do that
it's this thing it's the hand
you